[Música]
pues ya es momento de empezar con
nuestro espacio económico aquí en
directo América edición nocturna ya
tenemos para ello preparada nuestro
compañero Juan Pablo y Juan Pablo
bienvenido y vamos a empezar hablando de
Egipto porque en este país la gente ha
vuelto a retomar una práctica de hace
muchos años de qué se trata así es
Rodrigo Buenas noches pues los egidios
los egipcios están refugiando en el oro
ante la incertidumbre económica la libra
egipcia alcanzó mínimos históricos
frente al Dólar y el dato que se conoció
de la inflación es bastante alto
ubicándose en enero en un 25,8%
interanual y viene Rodrigo del 21 del 18
y del 16% lo que quiere decir que el 25
muestra una tendencia al alza la demanda
de oro en Egipto aumentó un 83% en 2022
esto respecto al 2021 las ventas de
lingotes y monedas de oro también se
duplicaron con creces del 2,1 de
toneladas 2020 al 4,4 toneladas en 2022
Pues bueno de Egipto pasamos a la
empresa tesla que anunció que pondrá
algunos de sus cargadores al servicio de
todo el mundo Así es Rodrigo al servicio
de todos al servicio o a la disposición
de todos los estadounidenses Es la
primera vez que el gigante de autos
eléctricos hace esto en disposición de
que cualquiera que tenga un auto
eléctrico No pues únicamente de los
autos de la marca tesla puede utilizar
los cargadores Según el plan se
instalarán 7.500 cargadores de la red
súper Charger y destination Charger en
todo el país para finales de 2024 este
plan del director ejecutivo elon musk va
muy en la línea del objetivo del
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
quien Espera que el 50% de las ventas de
automóviles nuevos en Estados Unidos
sean de autos eléctricos esto para 2030
y quien también prometió instalar 500
500 mil cargadores en todo el país
pasamos ahora a noticias de América
Latina porque los presidentes de
Colombia y Venezuela firmaron un nuevo
acuerdo económico de que se trata así es
Rodrigo una reunión que tuvo lugar en el
puente internacional atanasio girardot
más conocido como tienditas un lugar en
el que conecta a los dos países la
reunión dejó como resultado un acuerdo
binacional que a grandes rasgos tiene
como objetivo fortalecer el comercio
entre ambos países Esta es una
actualización del acuerdo comercial de
2012 que se venía arrastrando hasta
entonces también pues es un
fortalecimiento de las relaciones
comerciales bilaterales que inició esto
en agosto después de la posesión del
presidente Gustavo Petro tiene como
objetivo alcanzar 1800 millones de
dólares en 2023 bastante ambicioso Busca
también profundizar en el marco jurídico
de ambos países esto para adecuar
cambiar modificar algunas leyes Pues que
les permitan a ellos tener mejor
comercio entre ambos y pues finalmente
poder tener el acceso de los bienes y
materiales que tienen algunos países
tanto Colombia como Venezuela utilizar
esos bienes ahí mutuamente interesante
ver cómo avanza esta nueva relación
entre Colombia y Venezuela entre tanto
sea conocido que la economía de Brasil
presentó una fuerte desaceleración
Rodrigo la actividad económica es un
índice que el Banco Central brasileño
usa mensualmente para adelantar la
tendencia del producto interno bruto y
muchos economistas le conocen como la
previa del pib o el dato previo al pib y
vamos a ver los números porque viene
desde una viene en caída porque en 2020
un 4,2% En esta actividad de 2021 del
4,68 hay un pequeño incremento pero en
2022 casi que se recortó a la mitad en
un 2,9% y teniendo en cuenta la
tendencia de este índice también para
2023 ni siquiera los pronósticos llegan
al 1% entonces deja ver cómo estará o
cómo se presentará el pb esto en Brasil
habrá que seguir viendo cómo sigue esa
tendencia entre tanto vamos con Los
indicadores y hablamos precisamente de
los indicadores seguimos hablando en
América Latina porque pese al dato de la
principal economía la región que
acabamos de ver los principales
indicadores de México Argentina y Brasil
reportaron ganancias Estados Unidos
cerró en pérdida este jueves con el
anuncio de renuncia del ceo de YouTube
el director ejecutivo los tres
principales indicadores de Wall Street
se derrumbaron este jueves y las
acciones registraron su mayor caída en
cuatro semanas luego de reconociendo
también que la alta inflación se
mantiene más rígida de lo esperado las
bolsas europeas en cambio reportaron
ganancias al cierre el principal
indicador de Frankfurt de Alemania
reportó una ganancia del 0,18% al igual
que el de Londres mientras el principal
de París un alza del
0,89%. bueno otra economía que va
bastante mal desde hace unos años es la
del Líbano y hoy se han presentado
nuevos ataques y quemas contra bancos
del país por ello el ministro de
economía libanesa ha tomado algunas
medidas Rodrigo fue Amin salame el jefe
de la cartera económica a quien dijo que
ahora se permitirán los supermercados
fijar el precio de los en dólares
estadounidenses en lugar de la moneda
local la libra libanesa salam dijo que
con esto no se busca una dolarización
sino la protección del consumidor un
plan en el que los supermercados tendrán
hasta el próximo miércoles para aplicar
dicho control de precios y es que la
crisis económica que se viene
arrastrando desde 2019 se profundizó más
en los últimos tres meses la libra
libanesa ha caído a mínimos históricos Y
aunque la inflación ha venido en
descenso en los últimos cuatro meses
todavía la tasa está en el 122%
interanual Juan Pablo la cifra del día
Rodrigo decía yo que mi papá me enseñó
algo y es que es mejor dar que recibir y
es una práctica que tal vez aprendió
Michael Jordan porque donó 10 millones
de dólares esto a la fundación make a
wish la mayor cifra otorgada a la
organización y esto lo dio justo porque
mañana cumple 60 años Así que en su
cumpleaños el Dios está donación previo
a su cumpleaños Le felicitamos Muchas
gracias por este repaso económico nos
vamos ya con directo a